Strange as it sounds – accountants in Russia
live dangerously.
Article 160 of the Russian criminal code: Embezzlement.
I worked in real estate management.
Fraud is endemic – you find it in nearly
every company in the industry.
Usually the boss shoulders responsibility
for that.
But here in Russia it's usually the person
who brings the prosecution that wins.
That's what my boss did.
He filed charges against me.
My 'guilt' was quickly proven.
The investigator said to me: 'You won't walk
free – your case fills 19 files and it's
a year-long investigation.'
The
state prosecutor was looking for a three year
sentence.
In the end I got two.
First, I was on remand.
The time on remand was worse than being in
prison.
I was in a small cell with forty other prisoners.
They were always there.
I had no privacy.
When I then went to prison, I lost all hope;
I had no more dreams.
I just waited for it all to end.
It was awful.
Awful being ripped out of your familiar surroundings
and put into strange new surroundings.
It was a world that wasn’t exactly pleasant.
They took my family away from me.
Even though it was only me that was convicted,
in the end my whole family suffered.
Visits were only allowed every four or five
months.
I didn’t know how I would survive the separation,
without the chance to hug and kiss my loved
ones.
I remember the prison as a dark hole where
nothing happens.
Nothing at all.
When I arrived I was confused and disorientated.
Then I got angry.
Angry at a system that steals years from good,
innocent people.
I only know this because I've spent time in
prison myself.